It’s been a while since I’ve ridden a horse, but Andrea has lent me the lovely Annie today.
We're going to ride one of
our beautiful Beach trails.
The Northern Pegasus Bay Bylaw has a few rules you need to be aware of
when riding horses along the coastal strip.
Firstly, we need to stay on the designated horse trails
and give way to people on foot at all
times.
When we’re on the beach itself, we need to stay in the designated areas.
For horse riders most of the coastal strip is fine, but the Ashley-Rakahuri Estuary is off-limits.
We also need to stay below the last high tide mark
unless we’re using an access trail or avoiding a potentially unsafe situation.
And finally, don’t ride through any surf life-saving areas.
So it’s not too hard, it all comes down to basic commonsense and courtesy for others.
We’ve all got a part to play in preserving our beaches & estuary.